GUN, VIOLENCE AND OPIOIDS ARE
NOT THE ONLY EPIDEMICS
FACING THIS COUNTRY,
ANOTHER ONE IS MASS
INCARCERATION
IN THE UNITED STATES, LOCKS UP
MORE PEOPLE PER CAPITA
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
ACCORDING TO THE NONPROFIT
PRISON POLICY INITIATIVE,
MORE THAN 2 MILLION. PEOPLE
ARE INCARCERATED
ON ANY GIVEN DAY
AND THAT'S JUST WHERE THE
VICIOUS CYCLE BEGINS
RECIDIVISM RATE SHOW THAT
WITHIN THREE YEARS OF RELEASE
68% OF PRISONERS. ARE WE
ARRESTED? SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE
IDEA,
MASS INCARCERATION AND THIS
BIG VAST TOPIC.
MUCH OF THE FOCUS USUALLY IS
ON THE PERSON WHO IS
INCARCERATED
IN PRISON.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE LOVED ONES
ON THE OUTSIDE,
THOSE LEFT BEHIND
THE 2018 CRITICALLY, ACCLAIMED
FILM BLIND SPOTTING FOCUSED ON
A PAROLEE WITHIN THREE WITH
IT WITH THREE DAYS LEFT ON HIS
SENTENCE. NOW, THERE'S A TV
SPIN-OFF BASED ON THAT. REALLY
INCREDIBLE FILM, BUT THE TV
SHOW
CENTERS AROUND THE FAMILIES OF
THOSE INCARCERATED.
AND THIS SHOW HAS A
STRONG FEMALE
FOCUS STORYLINE, WHICH YOU
KNOW, THAT'S MY JAM IN
THE SHOW. ASHLEY'S LONGTIME
PARTNER IS IN PRISON AND
SHE IS LEFT TO RAISE AND
PROTECT THEIR SON
FROM A GROWING CRISIS OF
POLICE BRUTALITY.
GRAEME, AN EMMY
AWARD-WINNING ACTRESS.
JASMINE CEPHAS JONES PLAYS,
ASHLEY, AND SHE JOINS ME NOW,
AND I'M SO EXCITED
TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY. SO,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
SO, I LOVE THE SHOW
AND I LOVE IT BECAUSE
WHEN A SHOW IS BUILT AROUND
THE WOMEN CHARACTERS AND
IT'S NOT SORT OF LIKE
YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING IN
RESPONSE TO WHATEVER THE MAN
IS DOING
THAT'S MY JAM. SO
IN THIS SHOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN OTHER SHOWS,
MASS INCARCERATION. IS AN
ISSUE WE TALKED ABOUT, BUT
IT'S NEVER FOCUSED ON THE
PRISONERS. LOVED ONES, THE
INCARCERATED PERSONS
FAMILY. WHY IS IT SO IMPORTANT
IMPORTANT TO
YOU THAT THIS SHOW
FOCUSES ON
ACTUALLY, IT'S PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO SHOW THAT,
YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU SAID,
THE PRISON SYSTEM,
AFFECTS EVERYONE INVOLVED. AND
THAT IS INCLUDING THE FAMILIES
LEFT BEHIND
TO SHOW HOW STRONG
A FAMILY CAN BE
TO TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER. THE
FRIENDSHIPS THE FEMALE
FRIENDSHIPS,
YOU KNOW, WE SEE SO MANY
STORIES OF THE PRISONERS, BUT
YOU KNOW THIS THE IT
ALSO
AFFECTS EVERYBODY.
SIDE THAT IS
INVOLVED. AND ALSO
CONTINUES ON ALSO WITH, YOU
KNOW,
BENJAMIN
EARL TURNER'S CHARACTER.
HE PLAYS EARL
AND YOU KNOW HE'S ON PROBATION
AND IT AND IT'S STILL HE'S
OUT OF PRISON BUT IT STILL
HAUNTS HIM AFTER
HE EATS AFTER HE'S OUT AND
IT'S HARD FOR HIM
TO TO LIVE IN THIS WORLD,
YOU KNOW, OUTSIDE OF PRISON.
SO
I JUST THINK IT'S,
IT'S A, IT'S A,
IT'S A PURSE.
EFFECTIVE THAT I THINK.
IS INTERESTING FOR PEOPLE TO
FIND OUT MORE ABOUT
AND TO GET MORE OF AN
UNDERSTANDING
THAT
IT'S NOT JUST INSIDE THESE
PRISON WALLS. IT AFFECTS
ALL THE LOVED ONES
THAT ARE INVOLVED AND
TRICKLES DOWN.
AND YOU KNOW HOW THEY DEAL
WITH THAT TRAUMA, HOW THEY
DEAL WITH THAT DEPRESSION.
ALL OF THAT IS IS INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL AND I THINK THAT
COMES THROUGH IN THE SHOW.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT
THE SHOW THAT I LOVE IS THAT
IT'S UNLIKE ANYTHING ELSE,
LIKE IT'S ABOUT
SERIOUS ISSUES.
AND IT'S FUNNY
BUT THEN I'M LIKE NOT SURE IF
I'M SUPPOSED TO BE LAUGHING
SOMETIMES AND I'M LIKE, THIS
IS RIDICULOUS AND SCARY
BUT IN DISTURBING BUT ALSO
HILARIOUS AND
FULL,
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT JUST THE
TONE OF THE SHOW? BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S SO UNIQUE
AND ORIGINAL
THERE'S SPOKEN WORD WHERE
YOU'RE TALKING YOU'RE BREAKING
THAT FOURTH WALL, THERE'S
CHOREOGRAPHY
AND IT'S SO OAKLAND
AND THAT COMES ACROSS
IN EVERY SINGLE FRAME. SO JUST
TALK ABOUT HOW ALL OF THAT
COMES TOGETHER AND WHY
IT'S A UNIQUE PORTRAYAL OF
THAT
FAMILY
EXPERIENCE ON THE OUTSIDE OF
PRISON THAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
I'M SO PROUD OF THE SHOW
AND THE WAY
WE HANDLE THE COMEDY AND
ALSO,
YOU KNOW, THE IMPORTANT ISSUES
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
SHOW,
IT IS ENTERTAINING
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO LAUGH. AND BUT I
THINK THAT'S ALSO KIND OF THE
REALITY OF LIFE, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE PEOPLE LAUGH THROUGH
THEIR TRAUMA, PEOPLE
DEAL WITH TRAUMAS
IN SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND,
YOU KNOW, I MIGHT
IT FOLLOWS MY CHARACTER ASHLEY
AND SHE
GOES INTO
THESE HEIGHTENED FIRST
SEQUENCES.
AND, YOU KNOW, I HAD TO KIND
OF ANALYZE THEM ALMOST LIKE
SHAKESPEAREAN, MONOLOGUES
WHERE SHE REALLY OPENS UP,
YOU KNOW, WITH THE AUDIENCE
IT'S HER MOST HONEST AND
TRUEST SELF AND THEN
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
CHOREOGRAPHY IN THE SHOW WHICH
IS ALMOST LIKE
A GREEK CHORUS IN THE PLAY.
AND YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
BASICALLY
DANCING
OUR FEELINGS AND SHOWING
ANOTHER WAY. ANOTHER CREATIVE
WAY TO EXPRESS,
US. WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE
SCENE?
AND KIND OF,
YOU KNOW, THIS HAUNTING IDEA
OF THE PRISON SYSTEM AND THAT
IT NEVER LEAVES YOU ONCE
YOU ARE INVOLVED
WITH IT IN SOME
SORT OF WAY, SHAPE OR FORM
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, WE ARE
US AS ACTORS. WE ARE LIKE
THESE EMOTIONAL VESSELS TO
REALLY SHOW THE
HUMANITY
OF OF WHAT HAPPENS AND
YOU KNOW, ALL OF THESE
FEELINGS THAT WE HAVE, THAT
ARE
ARE COMPLICATED.
AND COMPLEX AND ESPECIALLY
THROUGH,
YOU KNOW, THE FEMALE POINT OF
VIEW
TO SHOW THAT MY CHARACTER
ASHLEY SHE IS, SHE'S AN
AMAZING MOTHER. SHE'S A STRONG
MOTHER. SHE'LL DO ANYTHING FOR
OUR FAMILY, BUT SHE'LL ALSO
BREAK DOWN,
YOU KNOW, OR
TRACTOR HOTEL ROOM, OR,
YOU KNOW,
BREAK THE FOURTH
OR HOW SHE'S FEELING
WITH THE AUDIENCE AND THAT IS
SO HUMAN AND SUCH A
BEAUTIFUL WAY TO
SHOW THE
COMPLEXITIES OF
OF WHAT
HAPPENS TO THESE PEOPLE. AND
YOU KNOW, IN THESE SITUATIONS,
IT'S SO FUNNY THAT YOU SAY
THAT YOU HAVE TO SORT OF FIND
THE COMEDY IN THE
TRAUMA. BECAUSE AS I
SIT HERE,
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PANDEMIC,
I'VE OFTEN ASKED MYSELF THE
QUESTION, LIKE I HAVE
NEVER LIVED THROUGH PANDEMIC
BEFORE. BUT LIKE WHEN
I SEE A FUNNY MEME ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC OR OR
EVEN LIKE THE
INSURRECTION, I'M LIKE, I
WONDER IF PEOPLE IN HISTORY.
MADE FUNNY
MEMES AND JOKES ABOUT SORT OF
THE TRAUMA. THEY WERE
EXPERIENCING,
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN PROCESS?
WHAT WHAT YOU
WE'RE ALL GOING THROUGH. I
MEAN YOU'RE MAKING INCREDIBLE
ART DURING ONE OF I THINK
FOR EVERYONE, NO MATTER WHAT
YOU DO
THE WEIRDEST TIME
IN HISTORY,
HONESTLY,
EVERY DAY IS DIFFERENT,
YOU KNOW, I REALLY CAN'T SIT
HERE AND BE LIKE I DO
THIS
ALL THE TIME BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT IT CHANGES, YOU KNOW?
I'M
I'M GRATEFUL AND SO
THANKFUL THAT
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK IN THIS
PANDEMIC AND,
AND GIVE PEOPLE SOME SORT OF
ENTERTAINMENT AND ANOTHER
WORLD TO ESCAPE TO. I
LIKE TO WATCH,
YOU KNOW,
A LOT OF
MOVIES AND
TVS, TO,
TO ESCAPE
AND, AND
I TOO HAVE, YOU KNOW,
SPEND TIME IF I CAN WITH MY
LOVED ONES AND MY FRIENDS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE
YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY
THIS PANDEMIC HAS SHOWED ME
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE VALUE AND
HOW IMPORTANT
ARE,
YOU KNOW.
ESPECIALLY AT THE BEGINNING,
WHEN, WHEN WE WERE
TAKEN. OH, THAT WAS TAKEN AWAY
FROM US. YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T
KNOW WHEN I WAS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SEE MY MOM OR MY DAD,
YOU KNOW, NEXT, I HAD NO
IDEA. SO,
YOU KNOW, EVERY DAY IS
DIFFERENT. I THINK WE ALL
HANDLE IT
IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS. SOME
MORE RESPONSIBLE THAN OTHERS.
BUT
IT'S A
DAY-BY-DAY PROCESS,
YOU AND YOUR DAD MADE HISTORY
BY BEING THE FIRST
FATHER-DAUGHTER DUO TO WIN
EMMYS IN THE SAME YEAR
AND YOUR HAT.
ALI TOUHEY GOT ALREADY AND
YOU'RE ONLY 32. SO
WHAT IS YOUR LIKE
GOAL SHEET LOOK LIKE AT THIS
POINT. WHAT ARE YOUR STRIVING
FOR?
OH MAN, I, YOU KNOW, I
NEVER WANT TO PUT MYSELF IN A
BOX. THERE'S THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT I WANT TO DO. I
JUST
WENT AWAY FOR A WEEK A WEEK
AND WROTE
A WHOLE ALBUM.
I WANT TO FOCUS
ON MY MUSIC AT THE MOMENT.
I'M I'D LOVE TO
CONTINUE TO
PRODUCE AND CREATE MY OWN
MATERIAL. I HAVE
A BUNCH OF IDEAS AND STUFF
THAT I'VE ALREADY BEEN WORKING
ON FOR OTHER TV SHOWS
AND MOVIES THAT I WANT TO
CREATE. SO
I THINK IT'S KIND OF ENDLESS
AND, YOU KNOW, WHATEVER KEEPS
PUSHING ME AS AN
ARTIST'S AND KEEPS CHALLENGING
ME.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO DO. I NEVER WANT TO
FULLY FEEL COMFORTABLE.
I LOVE THAT. IT'S LIKE BEING
AN ARTIST. THERE'S JUST
LIMITLESS POTENTIAL. YOU JUST
YOU KEEP GOING AND YOU KEEP
PUSHING
AND YOU KEEP CREATING. IT'S
BEAUTIFUL. JASMINE CEPHAS
JONES. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE TIME
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
SHOW. IT'S REALLY, REALLY
ORIGINAL AND IN
FASCINATING AND I HOPE PEOPLE
CHECK IT OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU